[موسيقى]
ارتفع سقف الطموحات لدى الجماهير المغربيه
بعد الانجاز التاريخي لاسود الاطلس في
مونديال قطر
2022 المدرب وليد الرجراجي طمان الجماهير
بان الفوز بالمركز الرابع سيمثل دافعا
للاعبين لتحقيق حلم التتويج باللقب القاري
الغائب عن الخزائن المغربيه منذ نسخه
76 لطالما كان الم في كل مسابقات كاس
افريقيا في مرمى الفرق الاخرى والحقيقه
اننا لم نحسن دائما التعامل مع هذا الضغط
وهذه التطلعات نحن اليوم امام تحد جديد
وعلينا ان نكون في المستوى لدينا التجربه
سواء على المستوى او المجموعه لاسعاد
جماهيرنا وتلبيه تطلعاتهم وان نكون في
المستوى المباراه الافتتاحيه امام تنزانيا
هي الاولى بين المنتخبين في كاس امم
افريقيا ولكنها السادسه بينهما في مختلف
المسابقات ويقف التاريخ بجانب المنتخب
المغربي الذي يشارك للمره التاسعه عش في
النهائيات فقد حقق الانتصار في اربع
مباريات مقابل انتصار وحيد لتنزانيا
ويتسلح المغاربه بكتيبه من المحترفين
بقياده رومان سايس واشرف حكيمي نجم باريس
سان جيرمان ونايف اكرد لاعب ويستهام
وسفيان مرابط سعيا للمنافسه على لقب
الكان
[موسيقى]
e